[Music]
in the education business we learn
something that's really wonderful to
know we like it a lot and it is that
there are some big words some very
fundamental words there's a number of
them education is one of them by the way
and you can spend your life figuring out
what they mean good is my favorite word
about that but another highly favorite
word by me is the word nature it's a big
old word it means a lot of things and
yet those things are connected it means
a little seed and it means the whole
cosmos it means everything
how do those meanings come to be
associated with that one word what is
the general rule first paragraph well
it's the fact that because of equality
and because all men are created equal
under the laws of nature they have the
right to hear the laws of nature and
nature's God isn't that the first
Authority cited in this right and
Christian over here mentions two other
places where God is mentioned in the
Declaration what were they they were at
the that where we talked about endowed
with inalienable rights by their creator
as well ste and when we pledged to each
other by the name of our divine
providence divine providence creator
laws of nature and of nature's God can
you think of another
No so the answer is supreme judge of the
world toward the end so what branch of
government would be the maker of the
laws of nature and of nature's God
legislative analyst lawmaker right God
is a lawmaker right what branch of
government would be supreme judge of the
world
yeah what branch of government would be
divine providence and the creator would
be like a founder right like a
constitution maker that's very
interesting that God appears in these
guises and these images the branches of
government when one of the charges in
the middle of the Declaration of
Independence is that the king who's the
executive branch has interfered with the
legislature and the judges
he's bended the legislature he has
removed judges he is interfered with the
trial by jury the king is trying to be
all three branches but the person who
can be trusted to be all three branches
is actually named in the document only
God right it's a very plain isn't it and
if you think about it for a minute he
might need an authority like that if
he's declaring a rebellion because of
the source of the law up to that moment
had been the king in Parliament and
they're saying no more
so King and Parliament have not passed a
law that says you can cut off from us
whenever you want to if they had they
could have used their authority but they
were saying no so they needed some
higher authority laws of nature
what's nature me it means birth birth
okay explain that
so we basically all come to be at some
point or in some setting and as we come
to be and as we grow mature we have some
sort of essence and to how as people we
live our lives or as other creatures
that we are you talking about all living
things right
correct not rocks and trees well trees
not not rocks because they don't grow
right mm-hmm
so what you're saying is that living
things have a way of coming to be and
they're born somehow right eggs you know
whatever human beings by the way are
very unusual in the way they're born
they take an incredibly long time to
grow up wait until you have children and
they will punish you as you have
punished your parents right I mean I'm
in the college business guy and look at
the age of all of you right and if I
call your parents they will be
frightened right because I'm the
president maybe something's wrong right
but if you were some other kind of beast
they wouldn't know who you are anymore
right child-raising is a big deal for us
and yet we have discretion over it in
case these point is this word nature is
the Latin word for birth and the first
meaning of the term nature is how does a
living living thing come to be but it
has to mean more than that right because
as he's pointing out things grow living
things grow this growth this term birth
the Torah means the process of beginning
and growth by which a living thing comes
to be but living things also decay and
to distinguish the moment when they
cease to grow and they begin to decay
you need some conception of what they
are when they're fully themselves
completely and fully themselves when
they have realized their
nature it's one reason we love to say at
the college we're helping them to become
human beings they just haven't made it
yet yeah your potential human beings of
course and you desert for a long era you
know on the best day an actual human
being but you know on the worst day I'm
not one either right so this nature
means us becoming fully what we are now
what would you mean by a law of nature
kind of rules that govern how things
should operate and I think one of the
problems that the founders had was that
the king was trying to control all laws
of nature as himself and really they had
a fundamental problem with that because
it wasn't their actual creator you can
make it specific right this that's good
that's very good Steve and you could
make it specific this way too because if
we say that a thing has a way of growing
well under what conditions does it grow
well like plants need Sun and you know
sequoia trees need space whatever makes
it thrive that's the law governing it
and the laws of nature and of nature's
God they're referring there to this God
that appears three other times right the
one responsible for the order of all
things and also the great majority of
them the one to whom they pray and
expect them to protect the revolution
that they're waging not all of them
thought that God was so but many did and
we're going to learn as we go that it
was a specific purpose of the United
States of America to be the first
country to make a complete and full and
happy home for people and thought both
ways about
because their idea was those whom
Christians who in great majority of them
their idea was you're never going to get
to heaven because somebody passed a law
saying you had to do
[Music]